I'm confident with that change it will
be one of the safest airplanes ever to
fly the 737 max will be one of the
safest airplanes ever to fly and we're
going to make sure the max is the safest
airplane out there to fly Boeing CEO
Dennis Muhlenberg making some big
promises at his company's annual meeting
in Chicago it's the first time he's
faced shareholders since two of Boeing's
new 737 max planes crashed within months
of one another
killing 346 people those incidents in
Ethiopia and Indonesia led to the global
grounding of the max plane and growing
questions about safety at the world's
largest commercial aircraft manufacturer
in the light of the crisis facing your
company and in the interests of Rio
nning the trust of the flying public
have you considered resigning I think
the important thing here again is we're
very focused on safety and I can tell
you that both of these accidents weigh
heavily on us as a company I've had the
privilege of working for the Boeing
Company for 34 years and we know that
lives depend on what we do we take that
very very seriously that's not good
enough for the families of the victims
and their supporters who gathered
outside the shareholder meeting to
protest
samia's dumo died in the Ethiopian
Airlines crash and her uncle wants
answers I think it's quite clear that
their sales and marketing drive was
reckless and they represented the max as
just the same as the previous 737 and
they withheld a lot of information from
operators than anyone concede that the
crisis with boeing 737 max planes has
already cost the company at least a
billion dollars this year boeing said
that its core profits fell 21 percent in
the first three months of 2019 compared
with the same period last year and it's
had no new orders for the aircraft since
it was grounded production has been
reduced down from 52 planes a month to
42 boeing is updating the software on
the max to decrease the power of an anti
stall system called MCAS despite all the
assurances that have been given here at
this meeting boeing still can't predict
when the
max will be back in the skies that's
because US regulators have to first
approve any updates to software and
training and then regulators across the
world must do the same and all the while
Boeing is battling multiple
congressional investigations civil
lawsuits and a possible criminal inquiry
it is a company under significant
pressure fighting to regain both trust
and reputation
Hanna Thomas Peter Sky News in Chicago